I absolutely acknowledge that there are
Pros to being super hydrated but for me
there's one massive con you have to get
up to pee all the time the other part of
is that you actually deplete your body
of minerals usually a faster rate than
you put them back in and so a lot of
people who actually drink a lot of water
end up getting more cramps feeling
shittier having headaches and I
experienced all this stuff I actually
went completely the other direction and
I only drink when I'm thirsty what a lot
of people don't know is that a lot of
food has water in it right about a pound
of fruit every day 90 of that's water I
think the obsession about water for me
if you're like dude I love drinking
water then drink water I don't care I am
sharing what worked for me and maybe if
you're somebody who pees a lot it
disrupts your day and it disrupts your
sleep then consider not drinking as much
water